Thank you so much for seeing me.
Well, I
can only tell you
what the spirits say
through me,
but is there someone
you'd like to speak to?
Yes, my
grandma passed recently.
I'd love to just talk to her
one more time.
Well, let's see
if we can find her.
Okay.
♪♪
I'm seeing someone,
it's a male
who died recently.
An uncle, a brother,
Ricky, Roadie.
Oh.
My Uncle Randy?
Uncle Randy, yes.
Oh, my God...
What--
Does he see my grandma?
He says
she'll be here soon.
He says he was in the
neighborhood
and he's just gonna hang out
until she gets here.
Okay, fine.
Now he's telling me you've
really grown up.
Okay.
No, seriously, you
look good.
You look
like a woman now.
All right.
He's showing
me a trampoline,
a little girl jumping up and
down on a trampoline
and a man watching her
very closely,
never taking
his eyes off of her.
Right, yeah,
he used to get me a trampoline
and a bathing suit...
like,
every year.
He wants to know if you
still use it
and if
so at what times.
I don't even know where
they are.
Is my grandma here?
Yes.
Oh my God,
Grandma, is that you?
No, it's still Randy.
Now he's telling you to relax
and not to worry
and he's
rubbing your shoulders.
Oh my God, he's touching me
right now?
He says you have a lot
of tension.
Two huge knots.
Oh, gross.
He wants to know,
are you still friends
with that girl, Erin?
Erin?
Pigtails?
Amazingly heavy sleeper?
Oh my
God, I'm leaving.
How much do I
owe you ?
Wait, wait!
Your grandma's here.
Grandma!
She wants to know if she
can bum a cigarette.